pas
activité territoriale et quelles sont
les conséquences pour les usagers sur la
qualité du service public voici quelques
unes des questions posées par les
sénateurs ils ont entendu cette semaine
daniel canepa préfet de la région ile de
france et jean marc rebière président du
conseil supérieur de l'administration
territoriale c'est donc ces deux
auditions que je vous propose de voir ce
matin bonne matinée à tous monsieur le
préfet merci d'être là de nous avoir
rejoints
merci à mes collègues de d'être présent
pour l'édition préfère parler sur un
sujet dont j'imagine qui connaît bien et
sur lequel il peut nous apporter à la
fois son regard son vécu son expérience
peut-être le faire le point je l'air gpp
tel qu'il a été conçu at elle remplit
droit de british prioritaires qu'elle
s'était donnée s'est elle passée en
bonne coordination avec les
collectivités à telus au delà de ce que
nous ont dit les ministres sur les les
bienfaits financiers on aura aussi la
cour des comptes on entendra aussi le
vrai dessus ce que vous pensez vous dans
la prochaine phase comment faut-il
d'affaires au vu de ce que vous avez
vécu dans la première phase alors c'est
peut-être ce qui nous intéresserait bios
et c'est une réforme de l'état qui s'est
fait surtout dans l'état à vrai dire le
président de la mef que nous menons
opposerait dit ça plutôt une information
pour les collectivités qu'une
concertation large concertation
dur dur en informer moi j'ai vu sur le
terrain comment ça s'est passé
mais comment vous aujourd'hui de ce côté
là vous vous le vivez avez vous assez
les moyens pour assurer vos missions
aujourd'hui pouvez vous le faire dans de
bonnes conditions
je rappelle que l'objet de la mission le
préfet s'est d'abord de mesurer l'impact
sur les collectivités locales avec
lesquelles ils travaillaient étroitement
voilà alors si vous pouvez nous faire un
petit propos introductif et puis ensuite
le rapporteur et mes collègues pour vous
poser des questions et nous terminerons
dans leur clause est un parti de façon à
ne pas vous mettre en retard pour la
suite de votre journée merci à vous
merci monsieur le président mesdames
madame messieurs les sénateurs tout
d'abord donc merci d'avoir invité le le
président de l'association du corps
préfectoral et des hauts fonctionnaires
du ministère de l'intérieur
donc en tant que président de
l'association évidemment il a un propos
entièrement libre
si vous interrogez plus tard le
président hu préfet de région d'île de
france laurent propos libre mais un tout
petit peu moins donc au niveau 2 de la
réforme
contrairement à ce qui a été extrait
souvent dit c'est réforme mon sens au
moins pour l'administration territoriale
de l'état puisque c'est l'objet premier
c'est pas l'ensemble de la révision
générale des politiques publiques c'est
plus précisément la réforme de
l'administration territoriale de l'état
autrement dit la réate qui vous
intéressent au travers de mes propos je
dirais que contrairement à une idée
reçue
ça n'est pas totale une totale rupture
par rapport à ce qui avait été engagé
précédemment je connais assez bien le
secrétaire général du ministère de
l'intérieur qui officie entre 2003 et
2006 pour dire qu' il y avait d'ores et
déjà un certain nombre
d'expérimentations qui avait été lancé
qui poursuivait début relativement
proche pour ne pas dire identique de
ceux recherchés par la réforme de
l'administration territoriale de l'état
en 2007 2008
quels sont ils ces objectifs
ils sont d'abord une meilleure
lisibilité de
l'état dans sa dimension territoriale la
multiplication des administrations
territoriales de l'état et de leur
représentation tant au niveau régional
qu'au niveau départemental faisait qu'
il y avait ou un manque de lisibilité ou
un jeu pervers hante au niveau des
services de l'état dans la mesure où il
pouvait avoir sur chacun des problèmes
des visions susceptible dé différents
douars contradictoires et par conséquent
d'introduire le trouble le doute ou
l'utilité suivant le cas des
collectivités territoriales ou de leurs
représentants
donc premier effort celui de la la
lisibilité et de la cohérence de
l'action de l'état tant au niveau
régional et au niveau départemental
quand je dis que c'est finalement la
poursuite de l'engagement d'un effort
qui avait été fait à partir de 2004
c'est parce qu'il y avait déjà des
germes entre les expérimentations qui
avait été lancée de rapprochement fusion
de la drire et de la diren au niveau
régional ou bien au niveau départemental
de fusion dde d'edéa dans certains
départements qui avaient été engagées et
qui étaient allées à leur terme
et puis il y avait aussi des visions qui
n'ont pas été suivis plus tard ceux de
rapprochement entre les services de
l'emploi et les trésoriers payeurs
généraux et notamment une
expérimentation qui avait été lancée à
lille et qui n'a pas été un succès en ce
sens là si ce n'est si ce n'est
d'ailleurs qu'il a inspirés d'une
certaine façon très immodestement la
position du gouvernement d'un 2007 qui a
rapproché effectivement ce qui était
financier de l'emploi donc on peut
toujours espérer qu'on ait inspiré
quelque part une réflexion sur
le rapport entre les financer l'emploi
voilà un petit peu la première premier
thème donc la visibilité la cohérence
des services de l'état ma réponse sur la
question at on réussi je dis oui oui
sans nul doute simplification puisque
autour de la table du conseil
ce que j'appelle y là aussi de manière
inconséquente le conseil
d'administration de l'état c'est-à-dire
le cas il y a beaucoup moins de monde
il y a donc si grande si grande
direction plus celles qui ont été
confirmés si je puis dire je pense
évidemment au rectorat ou bien aux
halles agences régionales de santé qui
elle aussi a connu des évolutions mais
qui dans l'ensemble répond un en partie
à ce qu est l agence régionale de
l'hospitalisation
la deuxième deuxième caractéristique mon
avis la réforme de l'administration
territoriale de l'état
c'est le renforcement de l'échelon
régional
là aussi ça s'inscrit dans une
continuité parce que progressivement et
ce depuis les années 60 70 80 il ya eu
une évolution régulière pour renforcer
le niveau régional pour des raisons
évidentes de de coordination et de
nécessité d'avoir une action dès que les
politiques publiques soient conduits sur
un dispositif géographique plus large
que le seul département
et puis aussi parce que il faut hélas on
le dit moi mais parce que il y a
certains ministères qui avait moins de
moyens que d'autres et qui n'avait
d'expression qu'au niveau régional d'où
une espèce de convergence d'intérêts à
la fois d'une part et d'autre part de
volonté effectivement mon four ce niveau
régional ça s'est traduit d'ailleurs
dans le décret 2
2004 qui a été pris et qui renforçait
véritablement le rôle du préfet de
région dans la conduite des politiques
publiques et ça s'est accentué
ça s'est réaffirmée de manière plus
forte encore
donc en 2010 je crois que c'est la date
à laquelle a été pris un nouveau décret
pour fixer l'organisation territoriale
de l'état notamment le rentrer le préfet
de région et les et les préfets de
département donc renforcement du niveau
régional qui se traduit d'ailleurs par
une dichotomie au niveau de
l'organisation de l'administration
d'état
vous avez au niveau régional
une logique qui se décline à partir de
l'administration centrale les directions
régionales pour l'essentiel
correspondent aux principaux ministères
qui ont une action ou des actions de
politique publique sur le territoire
métropolitain ou l'outre-mer d'ailleurs
et puis vous avez un autre niveau qui
est le niveau départemental qui obéit à
une logique différente ce n'est plus une
déclinaison des administrations
centrales contrairement à ce qui se
faisait précédemment mais bien une
vocation à avoir une
une démarche beaucoup plus intégrée et
de nature totalement interministériel
d'où la position
les directions interministérielles qui
existent au niveau du département
la troisième caractéristique à mon sens
de cette réforme de la loi sur ce point
je dire c'est un constat plus qu'une
réalité
c'est le constat que l'échelon régional
renforce son saut visait pour l'état en
tous les cas en force sa conduite au
niveau des politiques publiques avec les
difficultés que ça pue d'ailleurs voix
générés dans l'esprit de mes collègues
de département qui au cours des années
2008 2009 ont eu un certain nombre
d'interrogations qui aujourd'hui ont
trouvé leur réponse pour la plupart dont
la définition d'ailleurs j'ai à dire
plus précise de ce qu'est ou du contenu
du pouvoir d'évocation
en un mot si vous voulez on est en
viendra si vous le souhaitez mais le
pouvoir d'évocation les préfets de
département craignais qu'il y ait eu un
court circuit de l'ordre de 2,2 du
niveau départemental et que bon nombre
d'élus considérant qu'il y avait une
capacité d'appel sur tout ou partie des
politiques publiques avait selon eux
aurait tendance à s'adresser directement
aux préfets de région ignorant le préfet
de département
en fait la définition du pouvoir
d'évocation a été bien précisées par une
circulaire de 2010 aussi qui vise à
limiter le pouvoir d'évocation à des
questions de nature générale donc pas
sur les cas individuels d'une part ce
qui très important en l'occurrence et
puis sur des questions de principe donc
donc moins deux des questions qui
intéressent directement telle ou telle
affaire précise donc la 3e troisième
dimension importante me semble-t-il de
la réforme de l'administration
territoriale de l'état
c'est d'avoir une vision qui est
british cherchons tous les cas à être
différente suivant l'endroit et
l'emplacement de considérer sous variant
d'une région à l'autre ou d'un
département à l'eau c'est à dire en fait
et c'est intéressant même si je vous le
dire après ce que j'en pense je je je
crois que c'est une recherche
intéressante parce que l antre
véritablement on en conflit enfin en
tous les cas elle constitue une rupture
au niveau de la réflexion par rapport à
ce qui est couramment admis en droit
administratif français c'est-à-dire en
tous points en tout lieu
une organisation totalement identique on
a un effort timide sans doute mais un
effort pour modifier un peu le
raisonnement est essayé d'introduire le
principe d'égalité dans son objectif et
non pas dans ses moyens à savoir très
simplement que l'organisation
territoriale dépend des besoins du
territoire et dépend j'allais dire des
aspirations des citoyens qui vivent sur
le territoire alors je dis évidemment
ces modestes ces modestes parce que le
poids des administrations centrales
n'est pas totalement absent de toute
réforme administrative de l'état et donc
il y a une volonté des administrations
centrales d'avoir un système identique
en tout point du territoire
néanmoins il y a quelques points qui
sont intéressants à noter d'abord c'est
l'appréciation de l'importance
démographique du département dont dans
les départements les moins peuplés il y
a deux directions interministérielles
dont ceux qui le sont plus y en a trois
il y à la prison compte évidente mais
qu'il l'était pas forcément dans
l'esprit d'un certain nombre
deux responsables au niveau central une
dimension qui prend en compte d'autres
phénomènes de les phénomènes physiques
je pense au bord de lorsque les
territoires régionaux bordent les océans
et bien on intègre la dimension de la
mer dans les directions régionales qui
sont compétentes en matière
d'aménagement du territoire
on a également et excusez-moi la de
cibler un peu la région d'île de france
on a une organisation sensiblement
différente en région d'île de france
compte tenu du poids à la fois de cette
région 12 millions d'habitants mais
également en fonction des problèmes les
plus lourds qui s'y posent je pense
notamment aux problèmes de logement et
d'hébergement d'urgence et c'est la
raison pour laquelle il y a une
direction régionale spécifique qui a été
mise en place pour répondre à cette
difficulté
alors je disais bon bien sûr que c'est
un effort considérable par rapport aux
normes juridiques en vigueur dans nos
sciences administratives françaises
c'est on est loin du compte parce que il
est évident que dans ceux qui avaient
été suscitées ou proposées il y à vie on
souhaitait enfin certains en tous les
cas dont dont l'association du corps
préfectoral soit elle souhaitait aller
plus loin en termes de différenciation
en matière d'organisation pour mieux
répondre encore une fois aux besoins du
territoire sur lequel on exerce nos
activités voilà les les trois points qui
me semblent majeurs de la réforme sur
les trois points à des degrés divers
comme je voulais indiqué c'est plutôt un
succès on a une meilleure coordination
une meilleure lisibilité normalement sur
le terrain même si on a choisi comme à
l'habitude des sigles totalement
incompréhensible enfin ça c'est un grand
un grand sens français et puis on a
véritablement essayer ou mis le pied
dans la porte pour avoir une
présentation différente en fonction des
endroits où on exerce nos activités
alors ça serait limitée que de dire au
fond la réforme de l'administration
territoriale de l'état doit être réduit
à lui une simple réorganisation des
services de l'état ya aussi autre chose
autre chose que vous avez bien visé et
qui intéressent nos concitoyens et les
collectivités territoriales
c'est au fond d'avoir dans l'esprit je
pèse mes mots là parce que ça peut être
retenu contre moi mais dans l'esprit un
certain nombre d'évolutions de même
nature que ont eu les réseaux bancaires
il ya seulement 20 ans ou à peu près
donc on est en avance c'est à dire de
mieux utiliser
en fait les ressources de la technologie
pour passer d'une administration que je
qualifierais de d'exécution et 10 chez à
une administration plus de deux conseils
d'orientation et de matière grise
alors c'est pour moi l'essentiel en fait
de la réforme de l'administration
territoriale de l'état
et c'est celle sans doute sur laquelle
il faut réfléchir pour avoir une étape
une nouvelle étape plus que la première
des exemples de cette évolution qui a là
aussi a été lancé dans les années 2000
2004 2005 alors c'est pas qu'on ramène
tout ça mais enfin toutes les évolutions
et toutes les réformes demande du temps
dans notre dans notre pays peut-être pas
seulement dans notre pays d'ailleurs
donc on a lancé si vous voulez un
certain nombre d'utilisations de moyens
modernes au niveau de la confection des
passeports au niveau des cartes
nationales d'identité s'intéresse
évidemment les collectivités
territoriales on a également renforcé
j'allais dire la centralisation
relatives au niveau du département en
matière du contrôle de légalité
alors les deux façons d'ailleurs sont un
peu enfin les deux approches et où les
deux exemples que je donne sont un peu
différentes
au niveau des carnets d'entités et des
passeports on est bien dans une logique
de 2-2 - guichets et de plus
d'utilisation des moyens modernes pour
confectionner la carte d'identité le
passeport et pour finalement rapproché
le service du consommateur par rapport
aux producteurs pensent eux également
d'ailleurs un à la carte à la carte
grise où on a ouvert si vous voulez la
possibilité de de faire établir au moins
toute une partie du travail des cartes
grises par par des tiers qui agissent en
quelque sorte comme collaborateur de
service public
donc on est bien là dans une logique où
on a moins de personnel de cadro ces
pourparlers administration
et moins de guichet moins de réception
du public et donc facteurs à la fois
d'économie et d'externalisation d'un
certain nombre de fonctions et puis au
niveau du contrôle de légalité on est
dans une autre logique
c'est la réponse si vous voulez à une
montée en en difficulté par rapport aux
à l'examen d'un certain nombre de deux
thématiques qui nous sont soumis au
niveau du contrôle de légalité et qui
nécessite d'avoir des plateformes si
vous voulez totalement adapté
particulièrement affinée pour pouvoir
donner un juste sa juste mesure en
matière de contrôle de légalité
donc ça veut dire pourquoi je dis que on
en est que au début en ce domaine parce
que il faut véritablement si l'on veut
parvenir un véritable un total succès
sur ce point-là investir en matière de
gestion des ressources humaines et
notamment faire delà de la formation de
façon à assurer un glissement optimum au
niveau des emplois et de l'utilisation
des personnels qui sont sous notre
autorité en gros et pour parler simple
il faut former d'essai pour permettre de
nourrir d un peu plus de baies et de
former des bep voire des c'est
d'ailleurs pour qu'ils deviennent des
cadres ea parce que sinon nous ne
répondrons pas l'objectif qui est sous
jacent c'est à dire d'avoir une
disponibilité en matière en matière
grise au profit de l'ensemble du
territoire sur lequel on exerce propres
à répondre aux attentes de nos
interlocuteurs
merci de ce qui est un problème mais une
analyse totalement complète très
conceptuel moi j'ai bien aimé votre
formule faut passer d'une administration
niche
une administration de matière grise oui
c'est bien si je trouve que c'est une
bonne idée je vais laisser d'ailleurs
mes collègues pose des questions mais
moi j'ai tout de suite je vais vous
donner l'envers de la médaille ou tête
rentrer dedans dans le en dessous du
guichet quand j'appelle la préfète ce
soit à chaque fois 17h 17h30 tu 7h30 et
8h30 je tombe sur un tapez 1 tapez 2
pour service tapez 3 à taper 4 mai à
tout bon jeu mais déjà 5 6 minutes avant
de savoir où j'ai donc déjà fui dans le
guichet avec ça marche pas très bien
mais mes deuxième chose ordonne le
concret je voulais encore pas fait
connaître hier matin hier matin
j'appelle la préfète pour le dire mais
après fait perdre la commune où j'habite
petite commune 300 habitants la commune
a délibéré le 8 janvier pour modifier le
paie lui il ya des gens qui attendent il
ya des constructions qui sont en cours
il ya des régularisations affaire pouvez
vous me dire commissaires enquêteurs
qu'il était nommé où en sommes-nous
comment avance l'enquète quand
pourra-t-on aval réalisation la préfète
j'ai un secrétaire général qui le dit
bah oui on on semble que sénateur donc
très bien vu président mais alors où en
est on à vrai dire le dossier il est là
c'est vrai on l'a reçu le le 12 janvier
mais monsieur le président moi je n'ai
pas les moyens humains d'aller plus vite
et je commencerai l'instruction début
avril ce qui de facto va retarder de
deux ou trois mois pour les administrés
jetons c'est un petit peu je m'excuse de
tomber dans l'indre l'un deux sous mais
entre la vision nécessaire de la
régionalisation et ce préfet mais
régionalisation dont je perçois la
cohérence
mais à un moment on renforce le
département et au parfois l'éloignement
géographique les difficultés pour les
départements un peu éloigné pèse
j'aimerais que vous me donnez un peu
aussi le ressenti de cette vision hors
ile de france bien entendu puisque
problématiques sont pas moins
importantes ne lui même 2 par rapport à
ces sujets concrets qui intéresse ce que
là nous sommes là pour les collectivités
notamment les plus petites collectivités
voilà je reposerai plus de questions que
j'ai
mais je serai mais mes collègues
monsieur le rapporteur a bien entendu
poser des questions essentielles
voilà oui je serais tenté de se lier pas
d'impertinence dans mon propos mais je
serais tenter de vous répondre comme je
réponds aux organisations syndicales qui
m'interpelle avec la préoccupation de la
diminution des effectifs et des moyens
ne confondons pas les choses ce n'est
pas la réforme de l'administration
territoriale de l'état qui entraîne une
diminution des effectifs
il n'y aurait pas eu de réforme de
l'administration territoriale de l'état
y aurait eu réduction des effectifs donc
les deux ne sont pas liés il eût été
plus facile de faire une réforme de
l'administration territoriale de l'état
moyens constants il était plus facile
d'avoir une attitude qui ne consistent
pas couper le blé en herbe parole budget
c'est-à-dire d'encaisser les économies
avant même de les avoir faites donc je
crois que cette sont deux choses
différentes
alors si vous me dites est ce que l'on
va trop vite dans la diminution des
effectifs
je serais tenter de vous répondre oui
alors après c'est un autre débat faut-il
le faire faut-il pas le faire pour des
raisons qui sont de nature budgétaire et
d' équilibre budgétaire sans doute mais
effectivement il ya nécessairement des
répercussions sur le terrain d'autant
plus que nous avons il faut le dire là
aussi en tant que président de
l'association il m'arrive de le dire
des répartitions d'effectifs à
l'intérieur de ce grand ministère qu'est
le ministère de l'intérieur de manière
inégalitaire
on a des réductions beaucoup plus forte
sur la petite administration
territoriale de l'état
je rappelle que nous sommes moins de
trente mille agents et donc quand on
fait une réduction à due concurrence
entre les 30000 de l'administration
territoriale de l'état et les j'ai pu un
peu moins de 200 milles ce policier
évidemment il ya un écart qui est plus
lourdement ressentie sur sur par
l'administration territoriale de l'état
j'ai donné d'ailleurs dans la fiche qui
vous a été transmis en pourcentage dont
j'ai pas revenir dessus mais c'est une
réalité
par ailleurs c'est vrai aussi que on est
à la fois
contraint au niveau des effectifs et en
même temps au niveau du budget donc on
peut pas gérer dire se rattraper en
disant on va susciter pour telle ou
telle action qui nous est demandé de
manière rapide immédiate et momentanée
pour une montée en charge
on n'est pas en mesure de recruter je
dirais ou de faire appel à des
compléments au travers de cabinet privé
ou bien de recrutement temporaire ou
saisonnier donc je dire c'est toujours
sur le gr pardon le muscle parce qu'on a
plus de gras le muscle de des
préfectures ou des sous préfectures
donc on est bien on identifie bien alors
pour pour essayer de de survivre au
milieu de tout ça est de rendre le
meilleur service possible avec le
minimum de moyens
bah on essaye et vente est effectivement
de mutualiser alors j'ai entendu la
mutualisation du standard alors au
départ on a mutualisé le standard c'est
à dire que on a fait en sorte par
roulement qu'il y ait à standard qu'ils
soient pris dans chacun des départements
pour le compte des autres départements
de la région ou de faire des binômes
c'est ce qu'on avait fait depuis puis un
jour on a mis effectivement une réponse
un peu automatisé je dirais pour faire
des gains notamment des gains de soirée
voire de nuit qui sont quand même
conséquent
donc je pense que en effet si vous
voulez on a on a un problème on a un
problème de ce niveau là est un problème
qui se double je dirais dans un dans une
absence de révision des missions
l'émission ne sont pas totalement en
réduction je dirais même qu elles sont
plutôt en augmentation ce qui d'ailleurs
entraîne le total paradoxe dans le corps
préfectoral qui est plus j'ai une
mission plus chez eux heureux et moi
j'ai de moyens et puis une mission
peluche me pose la question comment je
vais y arriver
donc on est véritablement un peu dans
cette situation qui donne de grands
frissons
non seulement à ceux qui comme vous sont
en attente mais à nous aussi parce que
nous avons le sens du service public
nous souhaitons qu'il soit bien exécuté
l'ensemble de nos agents sont aussi dans
cet état d'esprit et je dirais que pour
conclure sur ce point que nous avons
atteint l'os et que effectivement des
nouvelles réductions au niveau des
préfectures aux fins du réseau des
préfectures des sous-préfectures serai
là pour le coup de maja et à sang moment
là je le dis très clairement et nous le
disons niveau de l'association
il faudra se poser la question du réseau
des sous préfectures et des préfectures
parce que nous ne tiendrons pas si vous
voulez la qualité de service égal avec
de moins en moins de personnes sans
qu'il y ait une révision de la carte on
c'est sûr que c'est assez sommes pas
pertinent de dire ça puisque c'est une
carte qui qui a été réalisé en 1926 donc
depuis rien ne s'est passé
les trois demandes de parole monsieur
revel fichiers doligé mai et de madame
la miss dynamite
donc c'est le rapporteur site merci
monsieur le président monsieur le préfet
vous avez dit il faut pas confondre
diminution des effectifs réorganisation
de l'état j'ai pourtant en mémoire en
tous les cas dans les auditions des
ministres que tant les objectifs de la
rgpp
il y avait une obligation de d'apporter
un service public de meilleure qualité
ce qui dispense une réorganisation de
l'état mais j'ai aussi noté une volonté
de productivité de performance liées au
non remplacement d'un fonctionnaire sur
deux vous voulez soulevé ce point sous
forme d'observation question mais je
pense que ça mérite d'être approfondie
deuxièmement vous nous avez indiqué
c'est tout à fait vrai que la rgpp sur
le terrain c'était réorganiser à partir
des régions
dans le même temps nous sommes frappés
de voir que cette réorganisation est
assez largement inspiré du rapport
balladur et que la réforme des
collectivités territoriales tel quel
sort très éloignés des conclusions du
rapport balladur c'est à dire que les
régions ne sortent pas renforcé
conforter et l'échelon départemental
est maintenu et même par certains côté
réaffirmé donc est ce qu'il n'ya pas là
une difficulté au quotidien devrait
également évoquer que on a donné comme
mission me semble-t-il au préfet de
région de coordonnées dans une logique
horizontale les services de l'état sur
le terrain et singulièrement en
département pour autant l'organisation
de l'état reste très très verticale et
il m'a été signalé sur des choses très
très concrètes
par exemple le personnel que chaque
agent sur le terrain continue à relever
d'un ministère avec une vision
horizontal et que le préfet de région a
beaucoup de mal à ajuster ses effectifs
pour tenir compte du départ du 1 sur 2
et de la priorité ou des besoins
prioritaires de tel ou tel service
autrement dit on est en train d' de
devoir mettre en place des mises à
disposition deux ministères ministère
dans un département alors que
l'organisation se voudrait horizontale
tout à l'heure un supplice heures sur le
contrôle de légalité nous disait qu'il y
avait une volonté le simplifier mais je
reprends sa formule qui était très très
fort qui nous a dit on a vraiment
l'impression que le contrôle de légalité
se fait de façon aléatoire et lorsque
l'on s'empare d'un dossier il est
examiné de façon tatillonne je cite ses
propres ses propres termes
enfin c'est un sujet qui revient souvent
dans les contacts que nous avons avec
les maires et le président sont en effet
aussi un peu d'écho à l'instant c'est
toute la question de l'assistance aux
collectivités territoriales et
d'assistance à maîtrise d'ouvragé
sans vouloir être trop longue on vous
envoyait questionnaire qui comporte pas
moins de vingt-deux question peut-être
que vous souhaiterez nous apporter une
contribution écrite j'aurais souhaité et
que vous puissiez nous dire quelques
mots de la rgpp en région ile de france
puisque nous avons un chanceux de vous
entendre et que la spécificité de la
région ile de france mérite peut-être
que vous vous exprimiez sur ce point
particulier
oui je sur le sur le premier point
productivité performance rgpp facteur de
productivité performance oui tout à fait
simplement j'ai pris soin de dire je
traite de la réforme de l'administration
territoriale de l'état et non pas de
l'ensemble du du paquet qui constitue la
révision générale des politiques
publiques
alors je dis je confirme que bien
évidemment il ya une recherche de
meilleure productivité tout en
améliorant le service public c'est un
équilibre compliqué mais c'est une
équation possible mais encore une fois
la productivité doit être le résultat de
la réforme de l'administration
territoriale de l'état et non comme un
postulat c'est à dire que on doit
effectivement faire des économies mais
des économies dues à une meilleure
organisation et n'ont pas commencé par
faire les économies et après chercher à
se réorganiser
c'est ça que je veux dire est que je
maintiens alors bien sûr que l'art la
réorganisation de l'administration
territoriale de l'état a amené des
mutualisations bien sûr qu'elle a amené
des suppressions de services redondants
et que tout cela a généré des effectifs
économiser et immédiatement repris bien
sûr donc on a pas d'incompatibilité
alors en revanche quand y'a une formule
qui est générale et globale qui est dit
qui dit un fonctionnaire sur deux qui
est supprimé moi je j'ai envie de dire
ou quand vous regardez et ça ça dépasse
un peu évidemment mais mes maigres
compétences quand vous regardez le
nombre ou le dd fonctionnaires
globalement c'est pas les 30000 de
l'administration territoriale de l'état
qui pèse bien lourd face aux autres
bataillons donc quand on a un endroit
donné
si l'on ne fait pas cette formule 2 1
sur 2 je pose la question combien
faut-il en supprimer ailleurs pour
qu'arrivé au total à avoir un sur deux
je laisse la question ouverte à votre
sagacité
le deuxième point sur le rapport
balladur alors bon je trouve que j'ai
eue là l'honneur et la chance d'y
participer à ce comité balladur
oui il y avait une sans doute une
volonté de ne pas affaiblir la région et
c'est un euphémisme
et il ya un décalage entre ce qui a été
arrêté par rapport aux conclusions du
comité balladur mais après tout c'était
des propositions et je dirais que il
faut qu'il y ait bien
pas nécessairement même s'il ya des
rapports et qu'il doit y avoir des
rapports
je crois qu'il ressort de l'état le
devoir de s'organiser
je vais dire en un terme sans être
conduits à systématiquement s'appuyer
sur l'organisation des collectivités
territoriales les collectivités
territoriales sont libres de s'organiser
en interne comme elle longtemps que
l'état et une certaine liberté de
s'organiser de manière qu'il juge la
plus efficace pour répondre aux missions
qui sont les siennes ne me paraît pas
anormale troisième idée
troisième remarque que vous avez fait
organisation très verticale et préfet de
région a du mal quelquefois oui je
jouais pas esquivé le sujet jus pour fin
j'ai cru dire dans mon propos que les
administrations centrales concevait ou
avait du mal à perdre tout ou partie de
leurs compétences et de leur pouvoir
je vais même jusqu'à justifier le refus
quelquefois leur position puisque
j'étais de l'autre côté du miroir
c'est vrai que le secrétaire général
d'un ministère lui est interpolé pour
dire il faut que vous fassiez un certain
nombre d'économies de moyens tant au
niveau financier qu'au niveau des
personnels
donc s'il veut atteindre les objectifs
qu'on lui fixe et est oblige
et dans la plupart du temps plupart du
temps d'avoir j'allais dire une une
action sur les actions du sur le sur les
territoires c'est la raison pour
laquelle il y à un système assez
sophistiqué au travers de la lolf avec
les les boks qui normalement permettent
d'avoir une discussion entre les préfets
de région et les administrations
centrales pour la répartition des moyens
cette discussion elle est à la fois
limitée elle n'est pas totalement
inexistante
il m'est arrivé de donner un avis
défavorable à tel ou tel bop et faire
remonter cet avis défavorable motivé
auprès de l'administration centrale qui
en a tenu compte soit pour l'exercice en
cours soit pour l'exercice suivant donc
il y a quand même un certain d'une
certaine logique
et finalement je vais vous donner un
argument que vous m'avez pas opposés
parce que j'ai envie de vous le donner
c'est au fond ce qui est le plus grave
c'est que l'administration d'une manière
générale n'a pas forcément une bonne
répartition entre le niveau central et
le niveau à territoriale on de ses
effectifs et surtout et pour moi ça
c'est le plus important
lorsque on estime ici ou là qu'une
mission n'est pas suffisamment bien
d'assurer ou que pour une question de
visibilité on veut donner une réponse à
une demande de nos concitoyens on a
tendance au lieu de passer par
l'administration de se poser la question
comment peut-on l'organiser comment
peut-on la mobiliser sur tel ou tel
problème
ben on fait une agence enfin
l'établissement public et posez vous la
question dans ses agences et étaient ces
établissements publics
est ce qu'on compte les moyens qui lui
sont mis à sa disposition
est-ce qu'on réfléchisse à une
diminution d'un sur deux non vous ne
direz pas ce qu'elles n'existaient pas
donc c'est un plus un contrôle de
légalité
il est aléatoire il était tillon deux
choses différentes
d'abord sur le contrôle de légalité on a
mis en en place des schémas ou des
stratégies de contrôle de légalité
normalement partout en début d'année on
décide des orientations qui vont être
prises au niveau du contrôle de légalité
sur les marchés
de plus ou de moins temps
sur tel type de collectivités
territoriales sur tel type de délégation
de service public sur tel type de de
recrutement d'agents contractuels
hoekstra donc normalement le contrôle de
légalité n'est pas aléatoire
il est ciblé en fonction d'une stratégie
alors bon reste à savoir si la stratégie
est toujours bien construite et ce
qu'elle existe dans toutes les régions
honnêtement c'est pas mon rôle d'aller
voir mais c'est en tous les cas pour ma
part ce que j'ai fait depuis un certain
nombre d'années où j'exerce des
responsabilités et qui a été j'allais
dire validé au niveau central et qui
donc normalement doit être mise en
oeuvre
tatillon oui sans doute sans doute
d'abord parce que celui qui est
contrôlée trouve toujours que le
contrôleur est tatillon même mois le
dire on est contrôlé sans arrêt donc
j'ai la cour des comptes sur le dos je
les trouve tatillon g contrôle d'état et
se trouve être bon donc c'est vrai aussi
que ça dépend des des femmes et des
hommes qu'ils l'exercent
je veux dire que ce qui à la richesse
d'une administration et sa force
finalement c'est que ça se réduit à
l'équation humaine avec sa richesse est
avec ses petites faiblesses dont payer
les excuses et s'ils sont trop tatillon
l'assistance aux collectivités locales
si je dirais que si l'objectif est de
faire monter en qualité les les
fonctionnaires de l'administration
territoriale c'est justement pour
assurer une meilleure assistance aux
collectivités locales
ceci étant dit c'est vrai qu'il ya des
questions importantes dans ce domaine
que qui peuvent se poser con qu'on s'est
posée
notamment eux
là le recrutement le fait de donner de
la visibilité aux responsables de façon
à les garder dans l'administration voir
leur rémunération
je pense que c'est un point pourtant
pourquoi parce que c'est vrai que la
réorganisation de l'administration
territoriale de l'état a diminué le post
le nombre de postes de déboucher sur les
territoires et donc par conséquent a pu
décourager et à décourager un certain
nombre de responsables de
l'administration territoriale de l'état
et notamment parmi les les ingénieurs et
donc nous avons là j'allais dire une un
risque d'appauvrissement qui est déjà
engagé
aujourd'hui peu de l'ingénieur des ponts
et chaussées qui viennent dans les
territoires au niveau d'un département
pour prendre la responsabilité d'une
direction interministérielle du
territoire alors qu'auparavant il était
classique parmi les d2 d'avoir des
ingénieurs des ponts et chaussées alors
je dis pas que c'est ce qu'il faut et
que les ingénieurs des travaux publics
se remplisse toutes fait le mais c'est
un signe un signe que j'avais d'ailleurs
mis en évidence dans le rapport que j'ai
fait avec monsieur falls sur le besoin
en termes d'ingénieurs dans l'état et
l'attention qu'on devait avoir en
matière d'accompagnement de leur
carrière
faute de quoi c'est vrai qu'il y aura là
un risque d'appauvrissement et donc une
conséquence sur l'assistance aux
collectivités locales
lesquels d'ailleurs sont beaucoup plus
fortes
parce qu'il ya beaucoup d'ingénieurs qui
vont dans les collectivités locales
donc finalement peut-être qu'un jour on
demandera l'assistance au collège aux
collectivités locales mais dans l'autre
sens pour que l'état soit système
la rgpp en ile-de-france alors pense la
réforme de l'administration territoriale
de l'état en ile de france vous faire
une confidence vous me direz qu elle
sera enregistrée l'enfant donc c'est une
confidence relative
je n'étais pas un fanatique pour la
réforme de l'administration territoriale
de l'état de la constitution des dréal
je trouvais que le chant était un peu un
peu excessif et j'étais plutôt sur un
souhait que j'ai exprimée d'une d'une
fusion de la drire et de la diren parce
qu'il ya une vraie logique
et puis du maintien de la direction
régionale de l'équipement dans tout ou
partie de son existence
quand je dis tout ou partie c'est que
j'ai jamais non plus été un fanatique
des dires qui éloigne là pour le coup la
gestion du domaine routier du territoire
bon chacun a ses idées je les exprime et
le moment venu
elles n'ont pas été entendues mais comme
on peut tu es tu aussi dans
l'administration j'ai refait la même
chose pour la région d'île de france
et là j'ai eu gain de cause c'est à dire
on aime tellement la dréal peu j'en ai
3g la direction régionale de
l'équipement et de l'aménagement qui
intègre la direction des routes et donc
co je reconstitue un ensemble où on à
l'équipement l'aménagement et puis les
routes parce que tout ça forme à mon
avis un ensemble j'ai une direction
régionale du logement l'hébergement et
du logement parce que c'est un problème
capital pour cette région
si on y répond pas on est au devant de
lourdes difficultés
il faut qu'on se mobilise pour le
logement et l'hébergement alors bien sûr
c'est pas uniquement au travers de la
l'organisation de l'état cesse mais au
moins il faut aussi qu'il y ait cette
organisation et puis la troisième c'est
le rapprochement auxquelles je crois de
l'énergie et de l'environnement de façon
à réconcilier ces deux ces deux
dimensions avec la constitution de la
laddh rieux deuxième particularité je
dirais dans l'arrivée
enfin la réorganisation c'est de prendre
en compte une zone extrêmement
urbanisées qui forment une vraie mais
véritable métropole sont voit d'ailleurs
en termes d'organisation des
collectivités de local à au rapport
balladur sur les possibilités de
réorganisation à ce niveau là donc c'est
la raison pour laquelle les directions
régionales dans un certain nombre de
domaines sont des directions également
inter départementale c'est à dire qu'il
y à une administration de proximité qui
est une unité territoriale pour l'adria
pour la dreale pour la driaaf
agriculture forêt faut dire qu'il y en a
moins aussi qu'ils sont donc sur les
trois départements de la petite couronne
pour dire choses et qui sont directement
rattachés à la direction régionale c'est
à dire qu'on est dans un système où là
véritablement il ya un poids de la
direction régionale plus lourd encore
puisqu'il gère jeudi en quasi direct
dans un certain nombre de départements
c'est-à-dire les trois départements
aggloméré pourquoi pas parce que tous
les problèmes qui se posent sont en
interaction
riber je mens logement voit bien qu'il
n'ya pas de différence
le transport l'aménagement et c'est tout
ça est parfaitement liés et puis
l'agriculture et la forêt compte tenu
des espaces agricoles dans les
départements de la petite couronne on
pouvait en faire l'économie de direction
départementale
voilà le deuxième originalité la 3e 3e
originalité c'est une originalité
je dirais de d'intégration totale au
niveau de paris la préfecture de paris
intègre en son sein et sur le même lieu
physique depuis maintenant un mois les
unités territoriales de l'aménagement de
l'équipement et de l'aco et la direction
de la cohésion sociale
on est dans un ensemble si vous voulez
sous l'autorité du préfet et on est
presque arrivé ainsi à une autre
expérimentation qui avaient été conduits
dans le lot sous le nom de 11 et qui
visait à avoir dans un certain nombre de
départements pas nécessairement par tous
mais une organisation de
l'administration de l'état qui était de
même nature que l'organisation des
conseils généraux avec une intégration
dans un seul service il est 16 heures 57
g cinq demandes d'intervention est ce
que chacun peut faire poser une question
me suis pressé d'y répondre en temps
parce que nous avons encore notre invité
nous on est
j'ai demandé à mes collègues dans
l'ordre et charles revêt pichon fichiers
monsieur doligé 1
madame monsieur couderc et puis le
ministre qui a demandé alors allons-y
poser une question au ministre préfet je
l'avais deux mais ça fait rien vous avez
évoqué les agences jeu peut-être que
vous pourriez nous dire un petit peu on
a l'impression que ça floride temps en
temps et qu'on voit mal comment ça
s'harmonisent et qui fait quoi de temps
en temps aimer le ma question principale
c'était à propos de le l'état a recentré
et s'est recentré sur ses missions
régaliennes de contôle notamment n'a
vécu la période faste où où on avait les
des des halles et des dieux qui
accompagnait les communes en termes de
dead à maîtrise d'ouvragé
est-ce qu'il ya incompatibilité entre
conseil et contrôle est ce que quelque
part tout le monde n'aurait pas et
gagner de temps en temps que les
fonctionnaires de l'état apporte des
conseils puisque derrière les fonds de
contrôler que ça faciliterait pas la
talent des uns et des autres merci
charles michel et moi je vais simplement
faire très très court je voulais
simplement vous interrogez vous avez
évoqué mais très rapidement le devenir
des sous préfectures ça que vous disiez
tout là on est arrivé ce qu'on pourra y
être au taquet chez nous en bretagne où
jusqu'à l'os et donc si on continue il
faudra sans doute se poser les questions
d'argent dont des préfectures et
sous-préfectures et moi j'ai plus le
sentiment que très vite maintenant les
sous préfectures vont être revues dans
l'organisation de leur niveau de service
oui donc j'avais 25 questions je
reposerai que 24 avr gagner du temps
donc je voudrais simplement savoir parce
que j'ai dix minutes tout le reste s'il
n'y a pas quelques services dans les
préfectures et sous préfectures qui sont
un peu en souffrance parce qu'on a le
sentiment que les collectivités qui ont
pris leur le plus en plus de pouvoir
leur ont fait perdre un peu de pouvoir
et qu'ils n'ont plus les moyens d
assurer
donc ça peut poser parfois quelques
quelques tensions et quelques
difficultés à lorsqu'il ya des problèmes
psychologiques intérieur de certains
services madame mm l'état et merci
beaucoup monsieur le président ce
qu'elle n'est pas en fait ça recoupe la
question surtout de monsieur rvc celle
qui m'intéressait le plus vous l'avez
dit en fait la réforme de
l'administration visent véritablement
changer de culture et à passer du
guichet au conseil est donc on revient
la question de l'assistance à maîtrise
d'ouvragé ou ou au delà c'est vrai qu'on
a la possibilité avec nos
intercommunalités de mutualiser des
moyens de se doter d' ingénierie
mais cela n'est pas suffisant je suis
présidente de communautés
d'agglomération et on voit bien
qu'arrivé à un certain niveau de
complexité
on peut avoir toute l'ingénierie du
monde c'est vrai que on venait ensuite
face à l'administration d'état nous
devons répondre à un certain nombre
d'exigences passer devant des autorités
environnementales devant un certain
nombre de mesures de respect de la
législation et du droit et ma question
c'est est-ce que comme l'a dit monsieur
revêt on ne gagnerait pas être dans la
coproduction et le conseil plutôt que
dans l'instruction même à très haut
niveau je vous avez vous l'avez dit il
faut qu'on ait de l'ingénierie la
matière grise de parts de toute façon le
cadre juridique est le nôtre mais est ce
qu'on ne peut pas imaginer organisation
de la coproduction quand on arrive à un
niveau d' avancées du dossier qui
permette de ne pas attendre l'avis
positif ou négatif ou les difficultés
mais d'être à un certain niveau d'
avancées du dossier
non pas dans l'état qui s'immisce ou qui
fait à la place des collectivités mais
l'état qui intervient à un moment où ça
permet d'être co producteurs plutôt que
dans
rapport voilà deux de d'opérateurs et
puis qui passe ensuite à une instruction
à une censure entre guillemets donc ça
c'est ma question et c'est vrai que ça
nous permettrait peut-être quelques fois
de perdre du temps d'éviter de perdre
quelques fois des financements lorsque
l'on est contraint ou même d'arriver à
des difficultés parce que ben on a un
dossier qui n'est pas toujours très bon
et qui peut susciter ensuite de grosses
difficultés
oui alors c'est tout à fait dans
l'esprit de ce qui vient d'être dit mais
c'est le ressenti
j'ai parfois le sentiment qu'ils aient
un effet pervers à la façon dont les
choses ont évolué et je le vis par
exemple avec d'une part le sous préfet
qui est toujours prêt à nous accompagner
à nous aider et par contre des
directions spécialisées dont la première
réaction c'est toujours de nous dire ça
n'est pas possible
voilà ça commence par là ont voulu
d'abord ce n'est pas possible
et il ya en a l'impression que les
fonctionnaires qui sont maintenant dans
ces directions spécialisées en fait
compense un petit peu la possibilité
qu'ils avaient auparavant d'être dans la
création en étant aujourd'hui dans le
contrôle strict voilà
c'est possible et que vous avez l'esprit
tellement bien bon très très très
rapidement dangereux regroupés sur
l'assistance à maîtrise d'ouvragé parce
que c'est un point que je sens être
capital effectivement d'abord la
complexité que vous avez terme
complexité complexité veut dire rareté
des hommes et veut dire regroupement
nécessaire si on veut être efficace
donc on est bien dans cette logique là
en même temps besoin de proximité
territoire et donc qu'on sait moi je dis
c'est possible c'est possible ajustement
et vous l'avez indiqué monsieur couderc
avec je dirais un sous préfet placé
comme pilote avec un droit de tirage sur
la capacité en matière de matière grise
qui est regroupé au niveau régional
alors après il ya une question de
management c'est à dire que il faut
véritablement assez le rôle du préfet de
région et avec les préfets des
départements que le sous préfet soit
effectivement le m le maître jacques un
peu c'est à dire qu'il n'a pas tous les
moyens
il sait où sont les moyens et il doit
être en capacité de les mobiliser et les
directions régionales doivent
effectivement à ce moment-là ce se plier
à ses orientations
deuxième thème la coproduction et
conseille plutôt que la position de 2,2
2-2 d'autorisation et finalement de
décision enfin décision tous les cas de
décision d'empêcher je partage tout à
fait cet avis j'essaye pour ma part
qu'il en soit ainsi
le plus possible il faut bien voir quand
même que on a une limite c'est à dire
que à chaque fois que il y a
juridiquement le besoin d'avoir une
décision ou d'avoir un avis
circonstancié qui va nécessairement
porter un jugement sur le dossier qui
lui est présenté juridiquement on ne
peut pas l'éviter en revanche qu'il y
ait conseil coproduction je pense que
c'est à la fois souhaitable et ça doit
faire partie du travail constant mais
préfet d aussi des sous préfets des
préfère tous les cas de d'apporter et de
et de gérer de manager les directions
régionales ou les directions
interministérielles pour aller en ce
sens avec la limite mais on revient
évidemment sur les moyens mais encore
une fois je pense que c'est plus une
question de management une question de
deux d'organisation de fonds sous
préfecture devenir de leur organisation
je pense qu'à un moment un autre sera
sur la table
la réorganisation des sous-préfectures
au niveau de l'association du corps
préfectoral
nous sommes un peu en décalage enfin
totalement en décalage avec les
ministères de l'intérieur c'est-à-dire
que nous considérons qu'il faut ouvrir
ce dossier
alors j'entends bien il est jamais sait
jamais le moment de l'ouvrir parce que
ayant ça va être une diminution des
sous-préfectures et hélas c'est une
atteinte intolérable à la
là j'allais dire haut standing le telle
ou telle ville donc immédiatement
j'en ai fait l'expérience un jour j'ai
eu le malheur de dire à titre d'exemple
on pourrait imaginer que entre je me
souviens entre boulogne et montreuil
il pourrait y avoir un sous préfet avec
deux sous préfectures
immédiatement les élus de montreuil sont
allés voir la ministre de l'intérieur
en dix ans le préfet de région il faut
s' il faut le virer parce que c'est pas
possible
voilà ce qu'il a dit voilà donc on sent
bien la la l'acuité du problème mais bon
ceci étant je pense qu'un jour ou
l'autre il faudra le l'ouvrir la has des
services en souffrance je ne pense pas
qu'il y ait des services aux souffrances
je pense qu'il peut y avoir des agents
souffrance oui ça sans doute là aussi il
ya une bonne part du management aussi et
puis de de redonner confiance dans
certains agents parce que moi j'ai
constaté dans la préfecture de paris
pourtant c'est pas la plus pauvre qu'il
y avait des des agents qui faisait la
même chose depuis 20 ans et donc un
moment donné je leur ai dit il faut
faire autrement autre chose
c'est assez compliqué donc il faut il
faut accompagner
donc c'est vrai qu'il ya du management
ceci étant dit c'est pas une raison pour
les laisser faire ce qu'ils ont fait
depuis 20 ans qui sert plus à rien
ce profil merci merci de qualité de vos
réponses temps vous avez pris pour nous
apporter une vision que que vous en avez
jeunes ont passé
merci infiniment j'ai mes chers
collègues va immédiatement prendre
présent de sésame pour que vous puissiez
tous être libérés à 17 heures si vous
souhaitez voilà merci de m'avoir répondu
à notre invitation et de venir nous
éclairer de la foi de votre vision de
votre expérience en matière de réforme
de l'état telle qu'aujourd'hui le csa on
va dire le ceat un comme ça le vix moi
je vais pas vous poser de questions
préalables petit nul seule question si
vous pouvez faire un petit techniques
propres à la basse vision
puis ensuite les collègues et certains
collègues ont déjà dû prendre pour les
raisons que vous pouvez comprendre cette
semaine encore actives sur le plan de la
vie démocratique mais on aura terminé à
17 heures pour chacun d'entre eux régis
qu auparavant ce qui devrait mois la
place une question je vous posais
introduction c'est quel est le bilan que
c'est attire-t-il aujourd'hui de l'aria
tu sais pas si les français
comprendraient bien ce que je dis
aujourd'hui je l'ait fait s quel bilan
quel bilan
c'est à dire monsieur présente ainsi si
vous m'y a autorisé quelques mots pour
dire ce qu'est cet organisme mairie
connu et qui ne le regrette pas
d'ailleurs puisque sa vocation n'est pas
d'être connue à l'extérieur et qui fera
que peut-être ma réponse vous en prend
de mire les limites parce que c'est un
organisme qui a été créé par un décret
du 29 novembre 2006 donc très récent qui
avait été précédé par la création
d'une fonction qui s'appelait le préfet
en mission extraordinaire chargé de
l'évaluation des préfets cette idée
était de 1999 quand le ministre de
l'intérieur de l'époque a considéré qu'
il fallait dans le cas de la
modernisation de de l'état de
l'administration que le ministère
l'intérieur ce d'hôtes d'un outil
d'évaluation de ses cadres supérieurs et
une évaluation qui n'est pas une
inspection et c'est une des premières
différences c'est à dire que le conseil
super ne respecte pas ni la préfecture
ni les services de l'état malgré le fait
qu'il comporte dans son intitulé
administration de serial territoriale de
l'état
son coeur de métier c'est l'évaluation
des préfets et des sous-préfets ça
représente de l'ordre de 100 à 120 euros
selon les années d'évaluation des
préfets et des sous-préfets et donc
notre propos n'est pas de nous attacher
aux outils de l'état de l'administration
mais bien au potentiel à la manière à la
pratique professionnelle fait des sous
préfets nous avons une deuxième mission
qui est du fait de la diversification
voulu du recrutement de ce corps
préfectoral
une mission de conseil d'accompagnement
pour ceux qui pour la première fois
accède au corps préfectoral donc et une
fonction de tutorat c'est la raison pour
laquelle sa composition c'est pour
l'essentiel lui préfets qui sont avec
moi car il y a dans ce métier beaucoup
d'informel beaucoup de pratique
construite par l'expérience et qu'il
faut arriver à transférer à celles et
ceux qui décident de s'investir dans la
représentation de l'état
et puis 3e 3e responsabilité c'est de
lorsque nous il nous est confié des
missions qui ne sont pas des audits mais
qui sont des évaluations et je peux vous
en donner une illustration c'est de
produire pour le compte du ministre
puisque c'est un organisme exclusivement
rattachée au ministre et son directeur
de cabinet du fait de lier la
sensibilité des évaluations nous
émettons un avis qui n'est que
confidentiel ce qui explique aussi qu'il
n'y a pas de publicité à l'activité du
luxe at et bien nous nous avons produit
un rapport récemment sur l'évaluation de
cette nouvelle fonction de préfet à
l'égalité des chances qui avait été créé
après les émeutes de novembre 2005 dans
les gays dans les zones urbaines pour
savoir si pour la conduite de l'action
publique il y avait dans le bilan forces
et faiblesses de cette nouvelle fonction
à mission des raisons de consolider
cette fonction de préfet à l'égalité des
chances dans les zones urbaines qui
avaient été touchés par ces tensions
dans les quartiers sensibles
c'est vous dire que les gens j'arrive
maintenant à votre question principale
que nous n'avons pas dans nos
délibérations à nous prononcer sur les
choix d'organisation que ce soit au plan
national ou plan territorial puisque
nous attachons à cette équation humaines
particulières c'est est ce que c'est un
bon préfet est ce que c'est un bon sous
préfet et si la question que nous nous
posons à travers la réorganisation
l'admistration territoire de l'état
c'est la première mort premièrement
est-ce que ce préfet ou est-ce que ce
sous-préfet conduit cette réforme dans
des conditions où le dialogue social est
actif ou il le fait en optimisant toutes
les compétences et savoir-faire en
recherchant la meilleure façon de
valoriser ses équipes beaucoup plus que
de nous prononcer sur l'architecturé
nouvelle qui qui qui résulte de cette
réorganisation
et deuxièmement nous essayons de voir
quelle quoi ça impacte le métier de
préfet sous-préfet et de ce fait qu'elle
doit être éventuellement les nouveaux
profils de ses représentants de l'état
dans ce nouveau schéma de réorganisation
de l'état
de ce point de vue même si la réate et
encore enfin très récent dans son
application puisque c'est à partir de
janvier 2010 que les dd y ont été
vraiment mises en place pour l'outre-mer
c'est encore plus tardif
les conséquences on sait bien quand on
touche à la structure et à des habitudes
de travail prennent du temps
s'inscrire dans les faits mais comme
dans nos évaluations nous attachons à
interroger les partenaires du préfet ou
ceux qui sont ses collaborateurs
les directeurs devenu directeur
interministériel me disent nous avons
perdu en autonomie mais nous avons gagné
à l'intelligence en intelligence parce
que nous sommes beaucoup plus des
collaborateurs directs du préfet nous
comprenons mieux les enjeux
d'opportunités et de cohérence globale
et de proportionnalité de notre réponse
qui jusque là pouvaient être très
spécialisés donc d'une certaine manière
un peu non pas indifférentes mais moins
obligés d'intégrer un certain nombre
d'enjeux complémentaires et comme de jeu
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans cette
proximité avec le préfet une équipe
ramasser qui se voit toutes les semaines
eh bien nous nous approprions des enjeux
que jusqu'à voleurs nous n'avions pas pu
mesurer et donc il ya le sentiment
d'abord d'inde d'un resserrement
quantitatif d'une plus grande capacité
de cohérence et d'une plus grande
réactivité en disant ben on a un circuit
beaucoup plus court qu'avant avec le
préfet de département et on a de manière
beaucoup plus informelle aussi qu'avant
parce que les profs est travaillée par
notre être le dde la ddr et c'est ce que
je ressens de la part alors j'ose
m'exprimer de la part de grands élus que
je rencontre puisque quand nous faisons
des évaluations même si le il est
difficile de d'objectiver ce qui est un
bon préfet rebond sous préfet c'est
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui fait la richesse
de notre approche et la modestie parce
que on a besoin d'ailleurs de l'avis de
beaucoup d'interlocuteurs c'est pour ça
qu'on va rechercher auprès
systématiquement du président de
l'association des maires du département
du président de conseil général
des parlementaires le leur avis sur le
mode de relation qui s'établit entre
l'état et son côté son représentant et
services et la collectivité etc
et nous nous ressentons cette
interrogation qui est celle notamment
des présidents de conseils généraux
voire des élus de grandes collectivités
dans deux communes en dix ans mais est
ce que le préfet sera pour nous toujours
l'interlocuteur pertinent dans cette
réorganisation de l'état est la
conséquences que nous en tirerons c2c de
vérifier si les préfets les sous-préfets
sont en mesure par leur potentiel
parleurs leur pratique et bien de se
continuer à s'affirmer par de nouveaux
savoir-faire comme étant les référents
sinon principaux en tout cas les
interlocuteurs privilégiés des grandes
collectivités ce qui suppose de changer
certaines pratiques
cela oblige les préfets à fonctionner en
réseau dire qu'il faut qu'ils aillent
chercher l expertise au delà de la
proximité immédiate et on le voit bien
que c'est nécessaire avec la complexité
des grands projets les grands programmes
sur les grands sujets actuels de risque
majeur il faut aller chercher il faut
savoir aller chercher experte il faut
construire un réseau d' influence pour
pouvoir être pertinent et faire entendre
les attentes du territoire il faut que
les préfets développent leur capacité de
travail en équipe autour du préfet de
région ce qui n'était pas aussi naturel
qu'on peut le penser parce que les plus
fins sont habitués à être les
responsables unique est un peu dans la
solitude de la représentation et de et
du métier d'autorité et donc notre
préoccupation est de voir s'il s'y en un
même ils ont cette compréhension de ce
qui doit être de certains nouveaux modes
opératoires mode de relation pour
garantir parce que c'est vraiment je
crois ce qui est est attendue des
collectivités garantir que le conseil la
réponse qu'ils donneront d'amour sera
dans un temps ramassée par rapport à ce
qui aurait pu être la confrontation avec
le cloisonnement de l'état qui était
quand même une partie du paysage
préalable à la réate et deuxièmement une
réponse dont la qualité fera la
crédibilité durable 2
du représentant de l'état et de l'
influence d'ailleurs de l'état pour que
la position l'avis émis ou là
l'acceptation de la coproduction dans
tel ou tel projet soit considérée comme
certaines est opposable
donc il y a là des enjeux un peu nouveau
nôtres et notre notre préoccupation est
bien d'essayer d'arriver à identifier
dans le charisme des membres du corps
préfectoral celles et ceux qui ont cette
capacité à évoluer comme je crois le
corps préfectoral a su le faire après la
décentralisation
il ya des moments de correction des
débuts des difficultés pour vivre ce
moment
et puis un d'autres qui ont su conduire
l'état dans un nouveau rapport avec
notamment l'aide et les conseils
généraux qui de longue date avait une
tradition de proximité d'implication à
travers les dispositifs exercée par le
préfet donc c'est pour ça que sur le sur
la réate nous ne portons pas de
d'appréciation en tant qu'organisme je
ne fais pas délibéré en tant que
président le luxe at lui par contre je
fais délibéré le chat sur chaque dossier
d'évaluation pour que nous essayons de
de garantir au ministre un avis haussier
pire est possible sur le potentiel et la
capacité du corps préfectoral a amené
sur le haut à long terme cette évolution
dans l'organisation de l'état et dans le
rapport avec les collectivités locales
qui doit être garanti dans cette
fonction de de qualité de la décision de
réactivité de l'état et de
simplification pour les élus de du
paysage public puisque un des enjeux de
la réate c'est de faire que le paysage
institutionnel soit simplifiée elles
sont confrontées à une grande diversité
d'âge ans de structures de toute nature
qui sont porteuses porteurs de mission
de service public
eh bien il ya un besoin de lisibilité
que le préfet le corps préfectoral
doit apporter pour le rétablir un peu un
état nous confortons et accessible
proche et accompagne en conseillant et
en même temps lorsqu'il le faut garantir
le respect de la loi le respect de la
légalité qui voit là excusez moi d'avoir
été un peu long dans mon propos mais
pour éviter toute ambiguïté sur ce que
peut faire le qsa tous ceux qui ce qu'il
comporte comme singularité dans ce dans
l'organisation du ministère l'intérieur
vous demander votre vie on sur le
fonctionnement de la rgt je vais laisser
monsieur le rapporteur vous poser les
questions
merci monsieur le président se protéger
j'ai bien compris que vous vous sentiez
pas autorisé forcément nous dire des
choses très fortes sur la rgpp pour
autant vous avez assisté sur la fonction
d'évaluation dans le cadre de la rgpp
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire un
petit peu plus sur les critères
d'évaluation du corps préfectoral par
rapport à cette rgpp
je pense que si le ministère de
l'intérieur attend de ses serviteurs
qu'il met en place rgpp il ya aussi des
instructions qui ont été données sur la
manière de travailler sur également les
priorités parce que il est clair ça nous
a été dit au cours des différentes
auditions que dès lors que nous étions
dans la règle du un sur deux il y avait
moins de moyens donc il fallait sans
doute se recentrer sur des priorités
donc dans cette évaluation je devine que
des priorités ont été définies par le
ministère dont je voulais en savoir un
petit peu plus sur les critères
d'appréciation par rapport à ses
priorités
la deuxième chose c'est je pense que la
faveur de ces évaluations les les
préfets dois vous dire des choses dont
le secret du confessionnal et donc sans
trahir les secrets de la république
peut-être que vous pouvez nous donner
quelques indications sur les difficultés
qu'ils rencontrent les attentes qui
peuvent être les leurs un seul de leurs
collaborateurs
et puis j'aurais apprécié vous puissiez
nous dire quelques mots sur le climat
relationnel dans tome de travail bien
évidemment entre le préfet de région qui
est le coordinateur et on a bien senti
qu'il y avait une nouvelle donne entre
le préfet de région et les préfets de
département et quelle est la perspective
que vous pouvez formuler par rapport aux
sous-préfets et taylor que au fond dans
la vie quotidienne ont un peu ressenti
que le préfet de département est
reléguée au statut et au fond ils sont
un sous préfet était quand même très
soul l'encadrement ou tout au moins la
vigilance du préfet de région qui avait
une vocation de coordination
préfet ce ministre notre évaluation est
simple je vous aime dire c'est une
vision un peu étonnante que de dire
danse mais nous évaluons dans quelle
mesure comme je l'aï dit tout à l'heure
un préfet ou un sous-préfet conduit à
son niveau pour la part de
responsabilité qui est la sienne cette
réforme en veillant à ce que comme je
les dis il suscite le maximum de
compréhension d'adhésion dont il ya une
aptitude et la pédagogie de la réforme
en interne voire en externe qui est
d'ailleurs un des métiers importants des
membres de corps préfectoral
représentant de l'état c'est de rendre
faisable l'application de la loi et des
grandes politiques publiques et de
trouver les voies et les moyens de
susciter sinon l'adhésion la
compréhension et cela vaut pour la rgpp
comme pour d'autres grandes réformes et
politiques moi je me souviens des temps
on pose souvent la décentralisation le
mystérieux nous avait dit vous êtes en
charge de porter la décentralisation de
la réussir et chaque fois qu'il ya de
grandes politiques en matière de
sécurité aujourd'hui donc la rgpp étant
une des priorités de l'état dans sa
réorganisation
notre évaluation pour d'abord sur cette
capacité pédagogique de bonnes
communications comme je les dis de
conduire un dialogue social vrai et pour
la réussir puisque par définition
notre vocation comme représentant de
l'état est de faire que la volonté de
celui ci se soit traduite dans la
réalité avec le minimum de tension et le
maximum de 2 de compréhension et donc
dans tous les outils de la rgpp nous
vérifions par exemple si le schéma
immobilier se met en place tel qui est
souhaitée je veux que cet outil parce
que dans toutes les interrogations qui
sont
j tine de la part des personnels et qui
sont façade est incertaine d'incertitude
il y a des éléments structurants de de
la certitude de la visibilité qu'il faut
donner est indiscutablement pour des
gens qui ont travaillé pendant 20 30 ans
dans un certain cadre d'un seul coup
s'interroger pour savoir s'ils seront
intégrés dans tel ou tel lieu parce que
ce n'est pas indifférent c'est tout un
vécu qui est remis en question et il est
essentiel que il y ait des réponses qui
souhaitent apporter des réponses qui ne
soit pas seulement inspirée par le souci
d'économie pour l'économie mais ce point
d' équilibre à trouver entre eux
l'optimisation en termes de coût et des
conditions de travail améliorées plus
est satisfaisante
j'évoque ceci pour vous dire que notre
notre approche céder effectivement
d'évaluer sur la capacité du préfet des
landes le corps préfectoral à aboutir à
la mise en oeuvre des outils et des
conditions structurante de de la mise en
place de la réorganisation avec les
outils de dialogue social et c'était peu
interministérielle qui n'existaient pas
ce qui est nouveau
chaque jusqu'à présent chaque ministère
travailler à l'intérieur lui même
désormais il faut faire que le dialogue
social soit partagée entre plusieurs
fonctions et statut est donc ce sont
autant d'outils pour lesquelles il est
important que le préfet se montrent
capables d'obtenir la compréhension des
syndicats leur implication pour que se
construise durablement les outils d'un
management moderne
donc voilà le deuxième point c'est que
dans l'essentiel en tout cas dans les
préfectures et les sous-préfectures de
la rgpp porte sur la réduction des
moyens touchant ce qu'on appelle les
fonctions de production c'est-à-dire
cartes d'identité passeports titre en
général et ce qui est pour nous
essentiel c'est de voir dans quelle
commande organiser la transition
parce que les choses ne se font pas pour
que ce soit là aussi faisable et que
soit préservé autour du préfet aussi
bien dans les directions
interministérielles qu'un la préfecture
les le niveau de compétences et des
expertises correspondant aux fonctions
qui sont affirmés comme prioritaire le
contrôle de légalité et pour avoir
entendu un certain nombre de grands élus
ou de présidents d'associations de
grandes collectivités locales qui
exprimaient des points de vue très
nuancée sur la performance de contrôle
qualité et bien et je moi même quand
j'étais en sous-préfecture je disais que
j'étais très admiratif à l'égard de nos
agents de catégorie a souvent b
quand je voyais sur leurs armoires le
code des collectivités le code des
marchés le code de l'environnement le
code de l'urbanisme et c'est trop leur
demander et on peut pas attendre un
niveau d'excellence dans ce paysage qui
est très exigeant puisque l'état peut
même voir sa responsabilité engagée si
le conte en l'égalité défaillant et donc
nous nous attachons regarder comment le
préfet sur ses priorités renforcement du
contrôle centralisation contre l'égalité
arrivent à s'organiser pour garantir un
niveau de compétence
pertinent pour répondre à cette attente
et de l'état et des collectivités
locales
donc voilà notre notre approche alors
deuxièmement vous me dites mais sûrement
les préfets ou les sous préfets doivent
devant vous un pieu à exprimer leurs
difficultés
moi je vous parlais très très
franchement les préfet nous sous préfet
nous je vois comme des évaluateurs
je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils se confesse le
plus sincèrement auprès de nous parce
que ils peuvent considérer que non je
sais non non mais parce que ils peuvent
sans doute considéré comme ça a affirmé
exprimé des interrogations des doutes
sur un signe de faiblesse ou de doutes
sur sa capacité et c'est donc vous pour
dire le vrai ils ont une vraie
interrogation c'est la capacité pour eux
de trouver à dans l'appareil d'état
des expertises de plus en plus
sophistiqués compte tenu de la
complexité des enjeux auxquels ils ont à
faire face
et donc c'est vraiment un enjeu central
cgt
récemment parce que dans notre fonction
de conseil on apporte aussi le fonac
cyprien se jeter dans les alpes
maritimes pour aider le préfet à
préparer le g20 et il me disait que sur
un certain nombre de grands projets
d'aménagement
il était très heureux de trouver le
conseil général du développement durable
et on voyait bien que sa nature dans je
n'étais plus du ressort ni du niveau
régional ou départemental mais qu'il
avait par son dans sa compréhension et
sa connaissance du système trouvé le
niveau d' expertise qui était d'ailleurs
utiles pour les élus et en même temps
très très précieux pour le représentant
de l'état
donc là pour pouvoir rester un
représentant de l'état crédible il y à
cette exigence profonde qui est que s
que l'ensemble de l'appareil d'état sera
en permanence ce niveau d'expertisé
qu'on est en droit d'attendre et niveau
régional niveau zone alternée vaut
beaucoup au niveau régional vous l'avez
évoqué monsieur ministre alain mai
il ya un niveau qui se renforce et on le
voit bien en matière de crise c'est
d'ailleurs le seul niveau ou un préfet a
une capacité de réformer une décision du
préfet département c'est le niveau zonal
ce que n'a pas le préfet de région et
j'évoque cela pour dire que notre
sentiment c'est qu'on n'est plus dans
une architecture univoque
on est selon les problématiques dans des
architectures extrêmement indigne enfin
complexe mais la complexité notre devoir
c'est de ne pas l'opposé aux acteurs
publics aux usagers et il faut que le
préfet soit capable de décoder cette
complexité pour offrir une réponse
cohérente unifiée aussi si synthétiser
que possible donc
l'interrogation fondamentale
c est ce que on préservera dans
l'appareil d'état
toutes formes y compris les agences 7,7
crédibilité que l'on voit d'ailleurs
absolument nécessaire que ce soit pour
la santé publique que ce soit c'est pour
un préfet l'hospitalisation d'office et
sont des sujets extrêmement sensible
est-ce que je trouverai dans mon paysage
de proximité
l'expertisé psychiatrique et c'est
qu'ils me garantira que six jeux
j'autorise je lève une hospitalisation
d'office
voilà donc ce sont des sujets vraiment
dans l'ordinaire de la responsabilité
des préfets extrêmement sensible et il
est très important que l'ue souhaite
apporter cette garantie par l'ensemble
de l'appareil d'état
voilà j'ai bien conscience sûrement
peut-être pour vous dire mes enfants il
peut il cherche un peu une peut-être ne
pas répondre directement je vous parle
très sincèrement à dire que je ne me
fais pas d'illusion sur le fait qu' ils
ne peuvent pas s'exprimer devant nous
avec une sincérité absolue parce que ils
sont nés dans un rapport d'évaluation
que poser une interrogation ça peut être
considéré comme
un élément d'incertitude et dans cette
fonction d'autorité
ils peuvent considérer que c'est une
marque d'insuffisances parce que ce que
nous évaluons par exemple c'est là la
capacité de décision
le discernement dans le métier de préfet
il ya un moment d'un rendez vous on a
tous une épreuve dans notre expérience
professionnelle et c'est l'épreuve de
l'ordre public
est ce que nous apprécions c est ce qu
un préfet sera prend la réponse de la
décision proportionnée
quand il faut décider de mettre en
oeuvre les forces de l'ordre j'étais
préfet en bretagne avec les
manifestations alors dont on connaît la
ténacité c'est pas indifférent de savoir
si on négocie sur négocie pas si on
autorise l'utilisation des moyens fort
et c'est donc c'est pour ça que je suis
moins ni pertinent ni compétent pour
répondre sur les choix d'organisation ou
sur les parce que notre venue
l'essentiel de notre fonction de cet
organisme peu singulier c'est bien
d'aider les gouvernements et les ennemis
les mises à l'intérieur à avoir plus
d'éléments d'appréciation pour être en
mesure de valider le choix de la
représentation de l'état et on voit bien
dans les crises qui s'intensifie qui ce
que le représentant de l'état doit être
en première ligne trouvé le ton qui
convient apporter la réponse et la
population ce qui suppose des talents
qui ne soit pas seulement technique
c'est-à-dire une émotion humaine que
l'on essaie de cerner beaucoup plus que
dans le détail de la mise en oeuvre
technique de telle ou telle
réorganisation on en voit les résultats
et on perçoit on essaie de percevoir
travers même la manière de manager
la capacité de quelqu'un a créé un
rapport de confiance avec des
collectivités locales il ya bien sûr le
rapport de conseil
il ya un contre l'égalité il ya quelque
chose qui est encore plus fort c'est là
le rapport de confiance qui fait que
malgré les divergences politiques ou
autres on peut conduire des politiques
publiques parce que son l'intérêt
général et on le voit je dis ça devant
le
président quand il s'agit des contrats
de projets au niveau régional on démarre
toujours de manière assez éloignées
entre ce que l'état reconnaît comme
prioritaires dans une région et ce qui
est la volonté du contrat et finalement
le sens de l'intérêt général fait qu'on
arrive à se rapprocher et on se
rapproche souvent parce qu'entre le
préfet le président de conseil régional
il ya un rapport plus que le seul
rapport entre un représentant de l'état
chargé d'un mandat et un présidents de
collectivités qui a aussi une forme de
mandat de son assemblée et cette
capacité à créer un rapport de confiance
elle s'exprime dans la relation que les
élus mais on a eu une intime conviction
qu'elle qu'on doit pouvoir la retrouver
dans d'autres moments de la vie c'est à
dire le management c'est à dire là y
compris la relation avec les médias
enfin tout ce qui fait le charisme la
carrure le l'identité d'une d'une
personnalité
voilà donc jeu et dans chaque région
chaque département plusieurs états avec
des directions et on voyait de temps en
temps des avis qui se contrarier entre
deux services de l'état bien il ya une
nouvelle organisation qui est en train
de se mettre en place
moi j'avoue que je préconisais que le
préfet soit le chapeau 2 to et le
coordonnateur de tous il semble qu'on
ait dans ce sens là est ce que c'est ce
qui est en train de se faire réellement
ou si malgré tout avec l'antenne qu'il
ya entre les services et et le ministère
concerné ya encore des différences
et puis deuxième élément vous avez parlé
des agences des agences tout à l'heure
votre prédécesseur un apple temps me
répondre à ma question et il ya de plus
en plus d'agents sont se demande
pourquoi faire de temps en temps mais ça
fait rien sa place du monde je vous le
dirai mai mais est ce que est ce que
c'est pas un élément qui finalement va
contrarier un peu cette nécessité
d'avoir un état auquel on puisse nous
élus s'adresser une un des axes
principaux de la rgpp c'est bien de
résoudre une une grande partie des
difficultés que vous relevez très
justement il suffit de penser aux portés
à connaissance que fait le préfet à
l'égard d'un maire sur la révision des
documents d'urbanisme
c'était une agrégation de points de vue
qui pour certains d'entre eux quand il
s'agissait de lutter contre le mitage
des des zones agricoles dans la
périphérie des villes et ce n'était pas
toujours cohérent entre la d des râles
des deux seins des éléments et ou durée
direction l'environnement où la drire
pour les établissements classés le
zonage des zones à risque et c'est un
des éléments constitutifs de la rgpp
c'est bien cela déjà s quand j'évoquais
le point de vue des directeurs qui
gagnait en intelligence et en
compréhension de cette exigence de
simplification
c'est que le directeur des territoires
déjà va être obligé
faire la synthèse qu'avant il ne faisait
pas quand il était d'aider ou ddea où il
pouvait s'entraîner au point de vue
spécialisés de sa direction
puisqu'il en lui-même l'ancienne dde et
l'ancienne dde et il est obligé de
produire le rapport de la direction des
territoires dont personne ne
comprendrait désormais qu'il continue à
être une expression diversifiée des
points de vue de deux secteurs de
sous-ensembles mais par contre comme
sept de ses directions
interministérielles ne sont pas
exhaustives dans le rassemblement
le préfet intervient parce que
effectivement la dréal ex diren reste
extérieur à la direction des territoires
et donc mais il y a
comment dirais-je un resserrement mais
qui n'est pas à ce point abouti derrière
des directions tellement horizontale
qu'elle résume murray et simplifierait
donc le préfet là se trouvent les encore
légitime et pour assurer une
coordination encore plus globale et y
compris avec les les agences comme vous
l'évoquez d'une part parce que le
système par le décret de février 2010 et
le circuit pwa ministre le préfet
désormais le représentant et le délégué
de chaque agence lorsque celles ci n'ont
pas d'unité territoriale deuxièmement
les unités territoire ces agences sont
placés sous la responsabilité des
préfets
aucune convention ne pourra être signé
les agences oui oui au cul qui condense
les agences de l'eau et tout ça alors
sur les il ya la part d'autonomie des
agences de l'eau surtout lorsqu'elles
sont financés par des taxes ce qui leur
donne une forme d'autonomie nez prenons
l'exemple de la politique de l'eau il
est exclu et d'ailleurs le directeur de
l' agence de l'eau sera dans le car
chaque fois qu'il s'agira d' arrêter la
politique de l'eau dans une région et il
sera obligé de s'inscrire
alors c'est pas dans un rapport
d'autorité parce qu'il ya un dialogue
avec quand on est dans une stratégie de
bassin le bassin ne se résume pas à la
région donc forcément mais d'où
d'ailleurs cette évolution dans les
métiers des uns des autres
collégialité avant un directeur des
agences de bassins directeur d agence
pouvait fort du la délibération de son
de ses instances et du point de vue du
ministère s'en tenir une approche
univoque
désormais il est membre obligé lorsqu'il
s'agit d'arrêter la stratégie de l'état
pour conduire une politique les nombres
obligé du quart des délibérations qui
sont formellement prise et il sauf à
hassan a franchi il devra s'expliquer
istres ou en tout cas le conflit sera
élevé mais l'ensemble de l'appareillage
est bien conçu pour qu' il y ait des
cordes de rappel pour éviter que
l'autonomie et d août des différents
démembrements de l'étang ne soit
supérieur à l'exigence de cohérence et
de jeu comme j'ai dit sûrement il
faudrait un peu de temps que pour que
tous les comportements s'adapte 1 parce
que quand on a eu la culture et
l'habitude de l'autonomie c'est pas
évident d'accepter de soumettre sans ces
orientations à ses objectifs la
délibération avec des prêts faits avec
d'autres services mais c'est une
exigence et et je pense que et
représentants de l'état et grandes
institutions locales
ils vont dans le même sens l'intérêt des
représentants de l'état comme des
grandes collectivités écoles c'est
d'obliger l'ensemble de l'appareil
d'état a effacé un petit peu la
singularité des organisations derrière
l'exigence et la politique de l'eau en
est l'illustration absolue c'est
d'ailleurs une des sources de la rgpp
quand en bretagne les décisions
individuelles sur les extensions
d'exploitations agricoles etc n'étaient
pas en phase avec la stratégie pour que
la france avait défendu devant bruxelles
parce que c'est elle en avait ont
surévalué le pouvoir réglementaire du
préfet de département l'état s'est
fragilisé donc une personne ne
comprendrait désormais que
dans un département puissent continuer à
autoriser des extensions d'exploitation
sans un certain nombre de mesures
d'accompagnement sur les et le
traitement des effluents et que dans un
département voisin
il ya une autre lecture donc tout le à
la fois les usages et les partenaires de
l'état et ceux qui sont obligés
d'assumer la responsabilité globale de
l'état vont dans la même attente est un
des enjeux majeurs de la rgpp sera bien
cela c'est à dire de donner plus de
force et de cohérence aux politiques
publiques pour l'essentiel porté par les
deux parlements je vais vous telle une
dernière question je vais vous titiller
un petit peu oui
j'entends bien mais pour nous on nous
parle des cartes grises j'ai encore pas
fait mais on n'est qu'un jeu grease en
disant mais c'est mieux puisque
maintenant les gens peuvent prendre leur
carte grise chez les concessionnaires un
code qui vont chez le concessionnaire
fait ils payent leur carte grise
il appelle donc ils vont payer pour
payer une redevance c'est déjà bien
difficile à pour le groupe pour celui
qui dit je ne peux pas payer la
redevance
il va la préfecture
côté la préfecture qui n'arrive le matin
à 7h30 pour l'approuver turquie
ouvrables à 9h à 20h30 à 9h30 qui après
que là que deux heures et moi
j'interroge la personne je suis allé la
voir qui était la préfecture pas de
besoins sans vous ai connu mais dijon l
avoir embêté parce que je suis toute
seule
regarder j'en ai 40 qui attendent 45 et
puis les concessionnaires vient de me
remets en dix ans le monsieur présente
pourriez-vous intervenir auprès de
monsieur le préfet pour que j'ai mon lot
de cartes grises qui me permettra de
livrer mes véhicules
parce que je ne les ai pas quand
j'appelle madame x 1 préfecture le me
dit le médium j'ai bien content mais moi
je peux pas tout faire
j'ai tout seul et j'arrive pas à vous
donner vos cartes grises à vous donc
c'est ça aujourd'hui on a réorganisé
l'état d'un scout moment de parler des
petits clients passeports des cartes
d'identité des cartes grises
voilà un domaine qui intéresse non pas
les collectivités là mais les
particuliers plutôt mais veut nous voir
dans les collectivités
c'est ça alors est ce que les préfets
moody's fait qu'ils mangent allez je
suis à loos j'ai du mal à assumer mes
missions aujourd'hui
ils n'ont mais forcément il ya des
tensions si j'étais préfet dans les
hauts-de-seine les files d'attentes des
étrangers le matin depuis 3 heures du
matin pour donc jeu on est confronté à
ça et le système est sous tension avec
aussi long on est dans cette phase de
transition l'objectif fondamental sur la
réforme des car ferries pour tous
d'autres c'est que l'usagé est un
guichet unique
le guichet naturel pour un usager de
pourrain acquéreurs d'automobiles
désormais à 90% ce garagiste latine
conviction de ceux qui ont conçu le
dispositif c'est de dire plutôt que de
l'obliger à démultiplier ses démarches
autant que ce soit le même prestataire
qui assure la totalité de la délivrance
et l'intéressé vient il prend sa voiture
il a la carte grise on est dans cette
phase de transition où il ya encore 20 %
le père tony's qui sont délivrés dans
les préfectures est bon et comme il n'y
a pas un système d'autorité il était
hors de question d'imposer aux
concessionnaires ou garagistes surtout
les petits garages dans les andes
rurales de devenir chargé de mission
série flics on est dans sa phase où le
système n'est pas complètement abouti et
forcément déjà les moyens s'ils
réduisent puisque on va vers les garages
et en même temps il faut préserver
encore donc je crois que l'un qu'il est
ce que vous dites d'insertion c'est un
président edgar faure disait le une
opinion c'est un fait
il avait raison on lit c'est
incontestable le sentiment c'est qu'on
est dans cette phase de transition où la
réforme n'est pas aboutie donc forcément
on cumule a encore l'inconvénient de la
double démarche où il faut encore
maintenir des moyens alors qu' il est
tard britz et qu'ils n'auront plus à
être là et et il faut en même temps
nourrir à alimenter le système des
garagistes qui est un système
contractuel aléatoire pour lequel ils ne
sont pas encore complètement avec des
personnels formés et c'est donc il y a
encore des scories dans le système moi
je le ressens comme cela et je pense
malgré tout que dans la dans la durée le
fait de dire un usager
vous avez une seule démarche à faire
vous avez un rendez vous pour votre
voiture et vous aurez tous alors
qu'avant vous deviez vous déployez alors
bien sûr il peut y avoir des
circonstances y
c'est quand même un progrès par rapport
à la démarche avec les contraintes
horaires et souvent je disais mais
personnel pensait que pour quelqu'un qui
travaille c'est lui demander de prendre
une demi journée dans les zones urbaines
pour les faire une démarche est bien là
aussi il ira chez le garagiste le samedi
parce que le garagiste est ouvert et
c'est normal commercialement parlant et
de ce fait ce qui était un surcoût pour
lui parce qu'on ne quantifier jamais le
coût de la demi-journée que devait
prendre la personne qui n'avait pas les
moyens de faire appel à quelqu'un
d'autre comme à paris des agences qui se
sont montés pour faire des marches donc
la vraie égalité républicaine c'est de
dire vous quelles que soient vos
contraintes vous aurez un service
équivalent par rapport à celui qui peut
s'exonérer de deux cas la liberté de son
emploi du temps qui peut à faire appel à
des tiers etc
mais c'est vrai qu'on est dans cette
phase où les arbitrages ont été rendus
il doit plus y avoir de moyens dédiés à
cette fonction de deux guichets à la
préfecture et pourtant il faut le
maintenir et la montée en puissance des
garages avec bon ce qui peut arriver ce
que tu y es mais je crois quand même que
l'intimé conviction de est le sens de
cette de cette unicité de
l'interlocuteur est quand même une
évolution moderne préfère mercialys
temps seulement qui vous remercie donc
merci beaucoup fait appel à notre
modeste plus insidieux c'est la fin de
ces auditions consacrée à la révision
générale des politiques publiques pour
les revoir notre site internet
publicsenat.fr
merci de votre fidélité et très belle
journée à vous